have you seen those bumper stickers
which say less people were hurt at Three
Mile Island than a Chappaquiddick what's
the truth to that Doug we have that a
guest tonight he's going to let us know
yes we're happy to have a special guest
tonight on alternative views Randi King
an anti-nuclear activist Randi was an
energy management consultant at the time
of the accident at Three Mile Island and
was soon after dismissed from his contra
company when he refused to work on a
Three Mile Island board control panel
since then he's become active in a lot
of anti-nuclear groups and is traveling
around the country organizing as part of
the anti-nuclear movement so Randi
welcome to alternative views thank you
could you to refresh our memories about
the Three Mile Island accident tell us a
little bit about it you were actually
living there at the time and experienced
firsthand the Three Mile Island accident
what really happened there well in the
morning March 28th 1979 through a
combination of technical errors and
human errors the worst commercial
nuclear accident in the history of the
nuclear power industry developed that
accident brought the core of unit 2
reactor to within a half an hour of
melting down and what would have
happened had it melted down if it would
have melted down it would have probably
have wiped out the entire eastern
seaboard from Washington DC to
Philadelphia to New York City my god
yeah how was that possible I mean what
would have happened well if the core
would have melted down it would have
melted through the bottom of the
containment building which was a four
foot thick concrete structure and hit
the water table beneath the island and
exploded in radioactive steam the
radioactive steam would have been
dispersed throughout the entire eastern
seaboard how close was there actually a
accident how close were we doing
accident we were within 30 minutes of a
meltdown a full-scale meltdown there was
some melting that took place within the
core and it is still in that state today
however they have been able to control
the chain reaction through a bore rated
water solution which
minimizes the amount of criticality that
takes place within the core itself but
the problem could develop and that thing
could still melt down sometime in the
future
now is the wide area of destruction you
mentioned is that just unique to that
place or could it happen in any nuclear
power plant well it would depend upon
the air patterns at the time in which
way the wind was blowing and whatnot but
that's fairly normal for any nuclear
power plant yes for instance one in
Dallas and the one that may or may not
ever be they gotten off the ground and
it's out the Texas nuclear project what
would be the destruction destructive
area if they were to Mel done in any
given direction approximately 200 miles
so that means if Dallas went it could
take out Austin yes Randy what were some
of the impact on the environment in
human life from Three Mile Island how
much radiation were people exposed to
and what were the consequences of this
well the exact amount of radiation that
we were exposed to will probably never
be fully determined and the actual
effects that the accident has had on us
will probably never be determined Dec
either at the time of the accident there
were seven radiation monitoring devices
placed around the plant only two of
those were operational the monitoring
devices that were on the stacks of the
containment building at the time of the
accident had a top reading of a thousand
milligrams they were off scale for
better than three three days after the
accident began so in effect we really
don't know exactly how much radiation we
have received I do know that in the nine
months after the accident the infant
mortality rates miscarriages and
hypothyroid diseases amongst young
children went up tenfold of human beings
in the human being so I've seen some
pictures in The Village Voice of animals
a lot of miscarriages or strange
creatures that were born from animals
so for Matiz of certain sites have you
seen any of these and just was this a
widespread phenomenon
in the areas that the plume passed over
yes and I have seen some of those
animals such as Siamese cows being born
and cows with three legs a cow with an
eye in the middle of its forehead a cat
with no bones in the back of its body
things of that nature it was very sad
one specifically specific thing were the
plume passed over it was about an acre
wide area and it hit some trees and some
of the trees had leaves on one side and
no trees on our no leaves on the other
side so there's no question and a lot of
radioactivity was released from Three
Mile Island and it had lethal effects
yes well they've been the radioactivity
placed into the water of the Susquehanna
River right joint in time of the
accident 2,000 gallons were released
into the river immediately afterwards
one of the anti-nuclear groups that
sprang up the Susquehanna Valley
Alliance held an intervention on the
dumping of water into the river and they
were successful in preventing any more
water from being dumped into the river
from the accident have there been any
indications of negative results from
this from damage being done either to
ecology or to animals or to people
because of the dumping into the water
just just in those infant mortality
syndrome in the studies that were taken
most of those cases developed in
Lancaster City in Lancaster County which
is downriver from Three Mile Island and
they get their drinking water from the
river Randy could you give us some
insight into how this affected you
personally and made you an anti-nuclear
activist at the time of the Three Mile
Island accident you were this energy
management consultant and your firm was
working with the Three Mile Island
nuclear installation when you anti-nuke
at that time or was only after the Three
Mile Island experience that you became
the anti-nuclear activist that you now
are at the time of the accident I was
not an Tanuku I wasn't entirely pro Nick
Euler over somewhat ambivalent the day
after the accident began I went to see
the China Syndrome and the China
Syndrome had opened in the Harrisburg
area on the day of the accident
I left the theater in a state of shock
and realized that the general attitude
of the people the utility
it was in that movie was exactly what we
were dealing with in the central
Pennsylvania area at that time from that
point on it became a personal crusade of
mine to never let that happen again and
that is the general feelings of quite a
few people in the central Pennsylvania
area we feel that it is our
responsibility since we have experienced
this and been through it to try and
prevent it from happening somewhere else
and that is why I'm in Texas speaking
and that is why I will be traveling
around the country talking to other
people as are my brothers and sisters in
the Three Mile Island area could you say
a few things about the claim you made
that the Three Mile Island incident was
similar to the China Syndrome first of
all was there the same sort of attitude
of the corporation that was producing
nuclear energy it was interested in
profit before human life is that was at
what you were least one of callous
indifference to the general feelings and
insensitive nough stew the people of the
area they seem to feel that the people
of the area are basically ignorant about
nuclear power and that is certainly not
the case for instance they found
radioactive rat droppings in the
containment building last year they
quickly said that there was no danger to
the public safety and that none of the
rats had left the island we asked how do
they know no the rats have left the
island do they take roll call every
morning that pretty much explains how
GPU deals with the general public were
you a member of the population that was
evacuated after three mile and how did
you experience this negatively or
psychologically when you learned that
there might have been a threatened to
your own life I was not forcefully
evacuated only pregnant women and
children under the age of six within a
five-mile radius of the plant were
evacuated but I did evacuate I woke up
about nine o'clock in the morning turned
on the radio and heard that there had
been significant releases of radiation
to the environment I was gone about a
half hour later that was a very quick
conversion then wasn't it too
and I suppose it after we left the movie
that evening we did some reading and
talking talked about evacuating that
evening we decided to wait until the
next day and and then make a final
decision as soon as we awakened the next
day it does that make you feel the fact
that you couldn't have the time bomb
ticking in you right now I'm resigned to
it
most people up there I've read studies
where the the people there's a high
degree of anxiety and the people up
there that's very true psychological
stress has taken a tremendous toll on
the people of the area and if any
physical effects do in fact show up the
first is going to be the effects of
psychological stress the general anxiety
the distrust of government and utilities
nervous problems guests or
gastrointestinal problems things of that
nature but yet the people are organizing
against nuclear energy there and again
we are organized right against Three
Mile Island being open can you say a
little bit about this how did you begin
your organizational efforts at the time
of the accident there was one
anti-nuclear group in the central
Pennsylvania area that was three mile
and alerts they had about 15 members a
week after the accident they had 2,000
members three months later there were
six anti-nuclear groups in the area with
approximately 25,000 members three years
later there are now eight anti-nuclear
groups in the central Pennsylvania area
with about 40,000 members all total
immediately after the accident we set
about trying to keep unit 1 shut down
unit 1 was down for refueling at the
time of the accident the NRC ordered it
kept shut down until they had determined
that it would be safe to operate a
number of interventions were undertaken
then by all of the anti-nuclear groups
and the Three Mile and Public Interest a
resource center was founded and the
Three Mile and legal fund the Three Mile
and legal fund was responsibility was to
disperse funds to the different
anti-nuclear groups to undergo the
interventions interventions were
undertaken on plant design emergency
management management competency the
venting of Krypton and so on and so
forth there has been a
two-and-a-half-year hearing process then
that has taken place and those hearings
all drew to a close in late October of
last year and what came out of hearing
what was revealed the atomic safety and
licensing board which heard the hearings
by and large said that the anti-nuclear
interventions were a waste of time and
money and that they had neither
needlessly postponed the restart of unit
1 one case in point the interventions on
emergent or on management competency one
week after the atomic safety and
licensing board issued GPU a clean bill
of health on their management competency
two operators were caught cheating on
their licensing tests four of them
failed those tests so they had to reopen
the hearings and retest the operators
under more stringent procedures half of
the operators then failed their tests
later so the actual results of that
operator cheating and scandal will not
be known for some time until those
hearings are concluded they are expected
to conclude sometime around the end of
this month the evacuation planning was
another major issue there are five
counties surrounding Three Mile Island
and all were required to draw up
evacuation plans within a ten-mile
radius of the plant most of the
evacuation plans stipulate that this
plan may not work in the event of a
nuclear accident because they are
expected to draw in volunteer firemen
and people just generally volunteers to
help with the evacuation they have said
those volunteers that they will not
participate in that that they will get
their friends and family out first and
then maybe come back in the city of
Harrisburg which is the largest city
close to three mond has only 60,000
people in it the 10-mile radius would
have split the city in half instead of
including Harrisburg in the evacuation
plans they felt that it would be
impossible to evacuate that many people
so they drew the boundaries two miles
short about eight miles and I live one
block on the other side of the
evacuation
line them so it's basically the
evacuation plans were constituted just
for the contingencies of practicality of
evacuating rather than the concern the
health and welfare and well-being of the
people absolutely think this is typical
about the political process that's
governed nuclear energy as well as the
corporate process of producing it I
think it could even go a bit further
into civil defense planning I think our
federal government may be preparing for
a nuclear war and this is one way of
preparing for it without letting the
general public know really what they are
doing could you elaborate on that idea
well around nuclear power plants now
they are putting up siren systems so
will defense siren systems they're
getting these evacuation plans together
and it just seems like there's more to
what is really going on than what they
are telling us of them what about
government industry collusion and
cover-ups in the case of Three Mile
Island there is a lot of talk about that
before and after the situation occurred
okay
the federal government of course under
the auspices of the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission which was split off from the
Atomic Energy Commission to regulate
nuclear energy instead of promoting it
the Presidential Commission on 3-mile
and found that the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission was more often promoting
nuclear power and actually regulating it
part of the problem that we have faced
is the lack of clean up that is taking
place at the time of the accident
general public utilities had 300 million
dollars in insurance money and they
predicted that cleanup process would
take 40 million dollars and six months
six months later it was four hundred
million dollars and five years several
months ago it was one and a half billion
dollars and eighteen to twenty years
they have no money to clean up Three
Mile Island now the federal government
says it will not give them any money to
clean it up so now the ratepayers are
being saddled with it their rates have
gone up some 70 percent we feel that the
utility in the nuclear industry and
nuclear till --'tis around the country
and the federal government either
funding or through legislation requiring
the nuclear industry to pay for the
cleanup is what should happen
is it even possible to envisage a
cleanup if it cost a one-point half
whatever billion dollars I mean it seems
research economically insane in other
words you want the cleanup but you don't
want the plant to reopen oh heavens no
right but if they clean up then
obviously they're going to want to open
the plant right there that just takes
them to the point of decontaminating and
removing what has been damaged in there
what they do after that is totally
beyond that one-and-a-half billion
figure well how far they actually
proceeded with the cleanup at the time
of the accident they dumped some 800,000
gallons of water into the floor of the
containment building the only real
cleanup that has been done is that water
has been processed through what's called
the submerged a mineralized system and
most of the radioactivity has been taken
out of it except for tritium it is now
stored on tanks on the island that is
basically about what has been done and
what needs to be done to make it say
radioactivity levels within the
containment structure itself and the
pressure vessel are very high almost
lethal if not incredibly lethal they are
not quite certain what the actual levels
are because the monitors were knocked
out of commission what needs to be done
now is the whole building needs to be
decontaminated the reactor core needs to
be removed is it possible they don't
even have a decontamination process if
they ever had a spill an accident on
this scale before we know for instance
that they don't know how to dispose of
the waste from the nuclear plant that
they don't have a technology or process
to eliminate this to make it safe and
harmless could it be the same thing for
the contamination of a plant on the
scale of Three Mile Island have you
looked into this they have done a great
deal of planning and preparations for
the cleanup of Fremont however the point
is that once they start doing it and get
further into it they may encounter
things that they were totally unaware of
they have a good guideline to begin with
we feel but it's by no means the bottom
line so even if the one
billion-dollar figures may not be the
end of the road oh absolutely not so it
could cause billions of dollars and the
consumers are being forced to pay for
this
yes higher rates do the consumers have
any alternatives or any course of action
they can take well we are currently
organizing as the project David rapier
strike that was launched several weeks
ago we are asking people basically
symbolically to withhold one month's
electric bill from the metropolitan
Edison Company the response that we have
gotten from it has been overwhelming in
the first five days it was over $100,000
now we are two weeks into the rate
strike I called our office today and we
were over 200 thousand dollars we are
getting petite between ten and twenty
thousand dollars worth of bills a day in
our canvassing operation on March 28th
at the third anniversary at the State
Capitol we will hold a ratepayers
Congress and decide at that point
whether to continue the rate strike or
not is this the crux of your organizing
efforts now you're a member of the March
28th coalition and the director for the
last resort is that some of the
activities project David is a campaign
being undertaken by the March 28th
coalition the last resort is a direct
action campaign that will be aimed
against the state government the utility
and the federal government if they
attempt to restart unit one probably
culminating in a blockade of three mile
and if they attempt to restore them
what's the status of the nuclear power
plants either an operation or under
construction around the country now I've
read where economically it's going down
the tubes construction is just almost
come to a halt in a lot of places the
NRC is ordering which of the one at
Diablo Canyon was at the yes license was
rescinded that looks like there's a
pretty rough time for the nuclear
industry and yet on the other hand
Reagan is saying full speed ahead on
news well I hate to say anything about
dear Ronnie but he said just recently
County Commissioners have said that I
have put referendums on restart on our
ballots for the many prime
Ronald got involved in that and said
that he felt the citizens of central
Pennsylvania didn't have enough
information to vote on restart whether
they wanted it or not he said that we
were basically ignorant the day after
that there was an unusual event at the
island and technicians went in and
discovered higher than normal levels of
combustible gases specifically hydrogen
and methane when you say the word
hydrogen in central Pennsylvania people
scatter very quickly we called the White
House to find out what they knew they
didn't know anything so we told the
White House we are doing that frequently
now calling the White House and asking
them information and they don't know
anything so we tell them Randy could you
say a few things about that February
problem or danger Three Mile Island
afterwards after they first of all it
appeared that this was going to be one
of the major catastrophes in history
sort of a replay even worse of the first
then they said wow this was just radio
transmission interference there was
really no problem there we just read our
dials wrong can you give us some
background or information on that at
approximately nine o'clock in the
morning on that Friday morning two
technicians went into the containment
building the instruments that they had
with them detected lower than normal
levels of oxygen which is normally about
20% and higher than normal levels of
combustible gases specifically hydrogen
and methane throughout the day they were
unsure of what to do they began Veni
the containment building to the
atmosphere to control this buildup of
gases at two o'clock in the afternoon
they went back again and detected it
once again then at 5:30 they finally
issued a press release announcing it to
the general public and calling for an
unusual event so there was that long of
delay if it would have been a serious
problem there would have been that much
time and between before the general
public would have known about it
at 5:30 when it finally broke on the
news hysteria reached incredible
proportions I went into our offices and
was on the phone for the rest of the
evening trying to consult people people
didn't know what to do they were calling
asking what do we do where do we go
all's we could tell him was get your gas
tank filled
and be prepared because we weren't sure
either then at 9:30 that evening they
held a press conference and said that it
was radio transmission transmissions
from two-way radios that the technicians
were carrying that we're giving the
false readings we believe that that is
true that is actually what happened but
that is indicative of the problems that
we have been facing the earth Imam you
know in Austin first ironically enough
we were coming up for a vote on whether
to pull out of South Texas nuclear
project during the Three Mile Island
thing it was voted down I mean they
voted to keep the nuke at that time much
to the surprise of a lot of people this
was done mainly on the dangers of
nuclear power the environment etc and to
individuals but it wasn't until the
obvious economic problems came up and
the mismanagement of the South Texas
nuclear project came up that Austin
people voted it down which indicates to
me that people still are not afraid of
the first part is the art of the
economics of it which seems to me rather
strange I agree that that said that it
takes that form but it would appear is
we are going to defeat nuclear power on
the economic issues what's this unit
without as an economically unviable form
of energy the Harvard Business Review
wrote a famous article which did an
analysis of the economic feasibility of
different energy sources and nuclear
energy was one of the most uh neck
anomic and they recommended a
discontinuation of nuclear energy and
the head of the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission himself said if you vote for
you clear power you're voting for great
increases in electrical rates that's
true there's another aspect of nuclear
power I think we should look into and
that's the great proliferation of it
overseas there was nuclear power there's
nuclear power going in in the
Philippines strangely enough there is a
court case recently in which some people
intervened in the United States to try
to prevent the US company from selling
the Philippines this nuclear reactor and
building it for them the judge ruled
that there was
that the people had no status that they
could not interfere in an American
company because they're putting it in
overseas not in the United States
another situation part of the same
phenomenon is the fact I've read where
nuclear power is being raised up in
Mexico and they want to start building
nukes but I wonder first time I thought
about that hey that's crazy they've seen
it was economically bad it's know
they've got all that other the fourth
major oil producer and then I saw an
article where it said Argentina has the
nuke they have the bomb you think these
third-world countries are doing this
mainly so that they can get the bomb
technology for nuclear weapon and devise
it rather than the energy itself
salutely is Randy are your group do your
groups try to educate the public on the
relationship between nuclear energy and
nuclear weapons that these things can't
be separated when I grew up in the 50s
we had Atoms for Peace where you had on
one hand peaceful safe nuclear energy on
the other hand you had destructive
atomic bombs whereas now we see that
nuclear energy is as dangerous as lethal
as nuclear weapons potentially but one
also shouldn't remember that shouldn't
forget that the problem is not only
nuclear power but also nuclear weapons
is your group making this a in the past
we have been fairly single issue
oriented it is somewhat easier for
people to deal with an issue if that is
all that you deal with now we are
leaning more and more towards making the
connection and there is a very obvious
connection there the federal government
is trying to pass legislation that would
take all of the waste from nuclear power
plants take it to reprocessing centers
and turn it into weapons-grade plutonium
alright this could be one of the reasons
why nuclear energy might be pursued in
the United States is to have the
spin-off for nuclear weapons technology
so that the people would have to be
educated about the insanity of nuclear
weapons as well as nuclear power we've
had quite a bit of this in Austin
recently there's a lot of good anti
where's Bergen Hiroshima or sister
cities mm-hmm what about excuse me what
about fusion you hear some people say
that fusion is the thing of the future
because fusion will give us great stuff
it's like the Sun and it doesn't have
any of the bad side effects of regular
nuclear power and yet he'll would call
this cod said that that's not true
well fusion still breeds radioactive
waste and as long as there's going to be
radioactive waste that's going to have
to be stored for thousands and thousands
of years I don't think that we should
pursue that course I think if all of the
money that were to go into huge fusion
research and fission research will be
put into alternative renewable resources
the entire country would have every
household would have a solar system
inside of five years Randy what do you
see is the alternative energy system for
America what you envisage as
alternatives that will meet the energy
needs of the country I think the first
thing that's going to have to happen is
a general change in the mindset of the
people of this country about the energy
that they use where it comes from and
how they use it and what it does to the
environment when it's produced and when
it's used once that happens when people
are more aware of what goes into turning
on a light switch and whatnot I think
conservation will take such a dramatic
toll in the amount of electricity that
is generated in this country or energy
that is used that from that point
alternative renewable resources such as
solar and wind and cogeneration and
hydro will more than enough supply our
energy needs Ron Carter brand-new album
song for you of course a real fine
version of that it was just amazing me
now I'm sitting here you know here we
are listening to these this music and
stuff like that and meanwhile the FBI is
running around trying to find a third
guy they already got to they're trying
to find the third guy in the plot to
steal a nuclear-powered submarine and
possibly destroying Eastern City with a
nuclear missile I mean this is real
stuff this is not a comics this is on
the on the news tonight
three guys tried to steal a nuclear sub
and blow up an eastern city with the
nuclear missile and they don't say which
city but I mean which one would you do
if you were going to blow up a city in
these
here we are sitting here listening to
the fine Tunes and stuff that is what I
call nuclear apathy it's something we
all suffer from India in the post-world
War two generation you know people that
were born in the 50s and 60s I guess no
clear apathy really who cares we could
blow up the world in ten seconds who
cares what's that got to do with the
price of tea in China
four minutes now left to go up beginning
all right several hundred feet in the
air you could see it from the lights
around the plant the white steam and it
roared an accident in the water cooling
system at the Three Mile Island nuclear
power plant in Harrisburg Pennsylvania
forced the company to call a general
emergency and shut down part of the
plant for an unspecified period it
roared with a tremendous roar of
releasing steam it woke me up and I
looked out the window and I saw this
huge column going up near and roaring
[Applause]
everything is under control
there is and was no danger to public
health and safety
there was a small release of radiation
to the environment all safety equipment
functioned properly
metropolitan Edison has been monitoring
the air and the divinity of the plant
constantly since the incident no
increase in normal radiation levels has
been detected it is my feeling that the
people within the radius of a few miles
especially pregnant women should be told
that they they think never could be
increased list to their babies and then
women who are carrying babies should be
evacuated from within a few mile radius
around that plant
nothing is riskless
but when one weighs the risks over all
the advantages of nuclear power the
situation is more complex than the
company first led us to believe we are
taking more tests and at this point we
believe there's still no danger to the
public health metropolitan Edison has
given you enough conflicting information
the new information is this the
accidents and ionized radiation beaming
through the plants four foot thick walls
consequently the metal shield that
protects the nuclear fuel may have been
damaged his continuing gamma radiation
coming out but the readings that I
obtained in this on the way here from
the airport indicate that it is not just
direct radiation from the reactor which
in fact goes down briefly when you go
behind a mountain but it is in fact to a
large extent not decreasing with
distance to a very rapid degree the way
you would expect from an inverse square
law so what we're dealing with is
fallout plain old bombs kind of fall on
the source of leakage radiation is
coming from our consumer building and
some water that's secured it on the
floor we're presently pumping that up
that'll be contained in tanks and once
that's accomplished well then the
radiation level releases uh should be to
stop the only way will show up will
probably be in the middle that we small
increases in radioactive I denote
because there is a accumulation factor
in the milk just wipe it was during the
fault incident we have absolutely no
question about they tune up we are plant
as a result of this mishap
we cannot refer to it as a nuclear
accident because it was not bad and as I
say all these systems went into
operation as they should have we think
the record of the nuclear industry
stands for
no amount of of a radioactive iodine
should be added to the diet of a
pregnant mother or a young baby the
principle concern is that the material
goes to the thyroid and will ever so
slightly lower the function of the
thyroid and it can lead to some degree
of retardation and grows not
tremendously series it would be
difficult to detect but it can lead to
some degree of a mental retardation and
that's why it is not a good idea during
times when there's radioactive fallout
in the air from bomb testing or from
nuclear releases to use fresh milk if
one is pregnant ionizing radiation
changes the electrical charge and the
chemicals in yourself thus on board the
living tissue the damages the cell
membrane that reduces mutant viruses and
it changes the genetic code it's all I
guess I feel like we're victims and if
not much we can do about it
and I do feel angry because I have a
little girl Adam for a mile away we do
have a new development it is not clearly
at the extent of this development there
was an uncontrolled release of radiation
from the facility approximately 20
minutes ago we were notified by the eye
now I think the wind had kept it and I
don't know I and getting my radiological
man in now he could come in and wear the
Geiger counter we want to take the in
development and instructed them to
develop a higher state of readiness with
the possibility of evacuation the whole
idea of being able to evacuate he's at
five is absurd it's been absurd all
along and it's just government on
utility nonsense to talk about being
able to cope with it situation by
evacuation because you're never going to
get the people out we are advising the
people on the basis of information on
the basis of a recommendation from the
chairman of the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission that they simply ought to
stay indoors as a precautionary measure
you know until they hear further word
from that simple
part of a fog or somebody in one little
region they closed their windows and
escape part of the goes but it's going
to spread out over the whole area and is
going to pay a price with all people
getting a faller goes a little further
down the area should be evacuated I
would say certainly in the immediate
area the Goldsboro area Middleton area
should be evacuated in terms of
Harrisburg yeah a lot of people are
leaving the Harrisburg area right now my
own family's on the way to New York City
right now to stay what relevant a lot of
people the gas stations are flooded the
banks were busy people were thrown some
of their money so they could get out of
here close all the windows in the
building like they've been told and we
in event heating and conditioning system
we had snow release of radioactive
iodine for example now this has not
generally been mentioned that the system
safety systems did work or capturing the
most potent effect how the nuclear
disaster wishes the widespread release
of radio I DS the release the release
that was made there may have been seen
on the scene on can be released through
water pits within acceptable limits
the release that was made yesterday was
within the limits that were acceptable
and was I don't know what I don't know
why we need to we need to tell you each
and everything that's that we do
specifically when we make possibilities
employment everywhere we certainly feel
responsible to the people that live
around the plant but one of the things
that the people that the grounds plant
have to recognize is that we have to get
on with our job well to tell you the
truth it doesn't bother me I'm not if
those things happen they happen and
that's the way I feel about it I think
they're keeping a lot away from us and
not letting us note our seriousness of
the situation our prime concern is the
safety the people of central
Pennsylvania and in order to assess what
we must do to protect their safety
we need accurate information I was by
the federal government given a budget of
three and a half million dollars a year
and a hundred fifty people at the
Livermore Lab to find out for them just
what the effective rate
we need accurate information and I think
the president agreed with me that we
needed a better capability after six
years of work we came out with one
report that that for any unit of
radiation any amount that you give a
person or group of people what will be
the cancer leukemia risk and we thought
that it would be twenty times as bad in
anyone had ever made it before and
promptly the government attempted to
Harasta and they took away my colleagues
12 of his 13 people and in a variety of
moves attempted in every way to RAF in
other word over happy to give me three
and a half million dollars a year so
long as I never said anything was we're
trying to keep everyone informed on an
ongoing basis we're on special alert we
don't know if they're going to be
further uncontrolled emissions I always
sit down to be pressurized but that
bubble keep dying to the core yeah I
don't think we want to be pressurized
just the latest book there are many
people
and after wiring up all the people down
there
I laid it down here protecting at this
point I think we already building people
how far out now I get down with
unfortunately the wind and still be
enduring these don't probability people
out to ten miles there are so many
people people about based on a right of
the chairman of the NRC and in the
interest of taking every precaution of
the dipole I am advising those who may
be particularly susceptible to the
effects of any radiation that is
pregnant women and preschool age
children to leave the area within a five
mile radius of the Three Mile Island
facility until further notice what's
right well it was it was in an extreme
apartment over there but now I'm
frightened
tell you the truth are you gonna leave
no I got no other place to go in the
where work or let me stress once again
with the historic record of nuclear
power has been an excellent one this is
the first significant nuclear accident
that we have experienced in power plant
operations in this country over is
Crimea if nothing happens to the workers
in these plans and they're claiming that
the people living next to the bomb says
nothing happened to them and this
government is going to take us over the
cliff if we let it we are told a failure
is mild which raises the question what
would have occurred if the safety
systems were severely attacked
hi I am concern
mr. speaker and want to understand what
reason I now have in believing not going
that other nuclear plants in the country
are safe for the people living over the
fact I think most people have realized
that these accidents have actually shown
that the design of nuclear plant is as
is claimed that they are designed to
accommodate just about any imaginable
mechanical or human error
I'll speculate but I do not know that
there were multiple failures because I
doubt that one would have gotten into
this situation with a single say about
that malfunction or a single function
which have been like your essence
Wednesday conflicting statements from
the governor's office the NRC here the
NRC in Washington and the company
metropolitan Edison that owns the plant
there's been a severe communications
problem by getting information back to
Washington I was there I think we're
very close to a chaotic situation part
of it I think is a lack of credibility
of what we're being told part of it's
the confusion that's coming forth
I think it's inexcusable that we leave a
private utility in full command of the
situation being advised and pulled and
tugged and fragmented by the structure
there I think you certainly have to have
military control we haven't heard
anything from the governor of The
Associated Press started moving a story
about 20 minutes ago that the hydrogen
bubble within the reactor is becoming
unstable
could be dangerous that would cause a
potential explosion and that's a very
ominous sign we are concerned though
about the status of the fuel in the core
there's extensive fuel damage how can
you say it's not an accident when
radiation is being detected as far away
as 60 miles the accident did not occur
inside the reactor in the slightest it
was a a feed pump connected to the
turbine outside of the reactor area now
that was a failure of a piece of
machinery and therefore it was an
accident of a with regard to it wasn't
an action of the failure of piece of
machinery there's also a bubble in the
reactor vessel that means any change and
the hydraulics for the core have to be
carefully monitored but we're looking
very carefully at the way the app
intends to get the coral cold shutdown
condition there's no relationship
between that and what it's thought of as
a nuclear action the risk involved is
that the gas will expand prevent cooling
of the core that we would suffer
additional core damage and with the
ultimate the risk of a meltdown that is
real
the risk depending on the manner in
which you figure up to cope with this
problem could be could be real most
likely meltdown is would not result in
early fatality that would Reserve and
would result in exposure to the public
that calls late in cancer and planned
the contamination and how far though
probably are resulting in economic
losses will be in dollars how far for
the most likely core meltdown operate
far I can't come to any other conclusion
than the early Wednesday that reactor
had a loss-of-coolant accident and it
would seem to me that the core may very
well be in the process is melting right
now we were suggesting that people
should simply prepare themselves to stay
inside
to get irate blocking agents to drink
bottled water I think we were telling
people we were expecting the worst and I
don't see how that has changed a bit
that we are just buying time doing
nothing and I'm simply terrified the
release of radioactivity with the
astronomical people within a few miles
would all die there would be a hazard of
enormous increased cancer risk to any
worth twenty to a hundred miles in the
downward direction and you'll really
have to evacuate as very as possible
maybe a million people that kind of
evacuation probably won't be like
possible yeah but that's of course why
the hole bigger stupid because it is
possible but you would try and of course
they might start evacuating in the wind
change direction and then there's the
cloud would blow right over well I still
don't feel too easy about it because uh
really they are not telling truth I
don't think it's more to it than what
says they said what are you gonna do
kind of kicks way over to here if it
does I can't
yeah have you been thinking about the
leaving gives your house no what's that
because I feel that the worst of the
thing is over now and I feel that before
they totally the worst was probably over
when they told her and I'm not leaving
they're going to still experiment with
it anyway so what it doesn't matter now
really because the money man with the
money going to what do you want anywhere
well thank you very much for being with
us and keep doing the good work thank
you we just hope everyone else around
the country will get mobilized by what
we are doing we feel that we have been
relatively successful in keeping unit 1
shut down and we just hope the people
around the rest of the country take
heart with what we are doing